make every day your masterpiece the
secret of your success the secret of my
success is determined by what we do
daily the more valid reasons you have to
accomplish a dream the higher the odds
are that you will how we view things
determines how we do things need
motivation watched up to end with
believe nation
what's that believe nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a man who
started his journey as a pastor in a
small church in Ohio to becoming a
leadership expert and a man who sold
over 30 million books worldwide he's
John Maxwell and here's my take on his
top ten roses success vol 3
enjoy also if you want to know what Jon
and other successful entrepreneurs have
to say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confident series where every day for the
next 254 days I will send you a morning
video for free to help you build your
confidence the link to join is in the
description below I've never met a
person who was not successful that
didn't have a great amount of
self-discipline within their life
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one make today count make every day your
masterpiece the secret of your success
the secret of my success is determined
by what we do daily and we've missed
this all the time I wrote a book called
today matters the reason I wrote the
book today matters is because today
matters we over-exaggerated yesterday we
just think we were amazing yesterday we
weren't just trust me
of course when you're my age 71 you
don't need to worry about it you forget
the other as in a car Margaret looked at
me she said John we're forgetting
everything I said we can't hire our way
she said let's do a plan I said what
your plan
she's it she said you remember who we
are and I remember where we're going hey
I want it's working
it's really working you got to divide it
up a little bit you got to divide it
effort we we over exaggerate yesterday
we overestimate tomorrow oh yeah
tomorrow you know I'll get to that
tomorrow oh yeah oh yeah I'll do that
too oh yeah oh yeah tomorrow tomorrow
tomorrow by the way good intentions are
worthless worthless folks when are you
gonna fall out of love with good
intentions they're worthless
good intentions are worthless unless
they lead to good actions nobody ever
had their life changed by somebody
hoping thinking good intentions are not
enough rule number two don't live
someone else's dream I wrote a book Oh
No maybe eight ten years ago called put
your dream to the test okay and it's
just it's just a good solid book and a
minute the kind of theses that book was
that the more valid reasons you have to
accomplish a dream the higher the odds
are that you will now that's a powerful
thesis so I mean that's there's no
cotton candy here there's there's no
hype stuff here yes and so I basically
they looked at what are the valid
reasons to achieve a dreamin and there
were ten of them okay and and so I I
formed it in in in a way of questions
but but the first one the first question
is is your dream really your dream and
that's where we started because it's
gotta tear something if your dream isn't
really your dreams ain't go to work and
and and I tell people look hey the first
dream we have isn't our dream it's a
parent's dream my mom and dad when I was
seven they thought I was going to be a
musician and so I've taken piano lessons
from the sailors over to about 13 I
wasn't any good it wasn't giftedness
it wasn't my gift but they're so proud
they go to Mars titles maybe you see I'm
living their dream I've yeah I'm playing
to be I can't play the piano very good
I'm not gifted but it doesn't matter
I've delivered their dream so what I
tell people all the time is we start off
our life living someone else's dream
probably our parents so what happens is
a lot of people as adults they never
switch so true and so they're still
living someone else's dream and again
it's you know it's in like a biblical
analogy it's it's King or David before
us keep putting on King Saul's armor hey
you know it's not it's not fitting they
staggered around there well I know a lot
of people they're putting on someone
else's armor and they're just aren't
going to achieve because it's not who
they are it's not it's not their dream
rule number three change your
perspective how we view things
determines how we do things that's just
an incredible principle yet now each one
of these I could preach 30 minutes on
but they won't let me do that but but
how I view things to determine success
so if if I view things if I do things in
perspective of wanting to serve with
excellence guess what I'll do I'll serve
with excellence if I view things in a
very kind of
average way than that I'll put a verage
into that into that endeavor so how I
view things is how I do things
let me give you another perspective
principle that's just huge - and that is
what you see is who you will be and we
see things not as they are we see things
as we are that's why two people can be
in the same situation same experience
same place and see things completely
different than anyone else so what is
before you isn't what you see who you
are is what you see rule number four
make a difference you see my journey on
how to make a difference was when I was
in my 20s and my assistant I was a
pastor I started off pastoring she gave
me a Christmas present it up and the
title it was a book in the title the
book was the greatest story ever told
now I love to read I thought oh my gosh
oh this is a what a title the greatest
story ever told I with great
anticipation open up the book and when I
opened up the book all much to my
surprise all the pages were blank I
looked I said well it says the greatest
story ever told
she said turn to the first page I turned
the first page and she had written a
note for me Dear John your life is
before you you fill these paces with
your dreams with your hopes with matters
of your heart you write your story and
make it the greatest story ever told I
took that book home with me and the next
morning I wasn't a writer at that time
at all next morning I started my writing
my first book and this was for me and
the first words on that black page the
first words I put on that blank page was
I want to make a difference because
that's exactly what I want to do I want
to make a difference so as you start to
take this make a difference journey in
our series that we've been doing on
vision this is the last of the four as
you start to make a difference journey
the first step one is I want to make a
difference it begins there it's already
in your heart it was sawed in your heart
when you were created I can soar ever
being in the fourth grade and walking
across the campus at
meaning my father was an overseer for
about 250 pastors and he was so greatly
loved and he made such a difference in
so many leaders life and I would hold
his head in a fourth grade I kind of
wanted to go to luncheon and it's only a
three minute walk across the campus but
for my dad it was a thirty minute walk
because he'd stop and pray with people
and encourage people and believe in
people and love on people and I would
watch people coming and just I could
tell how much they adored him and loved
him and I'm in the fourth grade I'm
saying when I get older I want to be
just like my dad I just want to make a
difference I just wanna I just wanna I
want to add value to be one I really I
just want to make a difference so when
you think about it when you're making a
difference your spirit is high your your
morale is high you you almost said you
feel good about yourself and you feel
good about others rule number five start
moving I'm responsible
Edie to move on what I see today mm-hmm
there's a whole bunch of people there
wanting to hold and not move because
they don't see three days five days you
know two years out whatever and what I'm
saying is it's it's kind of like the
lights of a car if I could the parking
lot and I turn on the lights and say oh
my gosh I can't go right I don't see my
house well no no no get the card start
moving in the direction supposed to move
it and guess what you only get about 300
feet of light you don't get seven miles
or like you don't get a see your house
you've got to utilize the light you got
oh so that you can get to where you want
to go oh so many people that's so
comfortable with that with that light
yeah because it's there's it well it's
not long enough and what's around the
corner and the whole issue is you don't
you know what you don't know what's
around the corner
do you go around the corner oh gosh
that's so good and so you just so you
have to be very comfortable which I am
yet to be very comfortable with
traveling not having all the answers so
true but can I tell you something the
only way you get all the answers is to
go all the way through absolutely you
don't get all the answers on this side
and so if I've got to have it lined up
and straight and right and I feel
comfortable with it then I'll never be
the leader and I
here I really believe this said I
believe a lot of leaders fall short
because they're unwilling to take what
they know now and act on it and so
therefore they never get to know what
they couldn't know rule number six shift
your mindset every miracle in the Bible
has one thing in common just one thing
in common trust me on this I've studied
it the only thing that come every
miracle in the Bible begins with a
problem you never see a miracle in the
Bible without a problem first there's a
problem and then American so what does
that mean well what that means is that
when you have a problem you're blessed
because you're a candidate for a miracle
you see the only person that has a
problem is the person that doesn't have
a problem you see if you have a little
problem you're a candidate for a little
miracle you got a big problem your
candidate for a big miracle I mean
choose the problem and choose the
miracle but if you have no problem
you're not a candidate for a miracle I
feel badly for you rule number seven
value people in the business community
the number one question they're asking
me right now is is how to deal with
Millennials and you know it's magazine
number two challenge yeah and and and so
what I say to them is this before we
deal with them before we fix them or
whatever we're going to do with them
they don't think they need fix that's
exactly but we don't oh we did I I share
with you share with these leaders value
them you see everything begins with
valuing people there are gaps obvious
age gaps thinking gaps but the first
thing you have to do is you have to find
common ground and the common ground that
I find with people as I value that
period no strings attached regardless of
age regardless of anything I value that
that's kind of Jesus like that's what he
did in the Gospels now the moment that
you value a millennial
you find some common ground you can then
begin to have some understanding of
which I say it's our responsibility as
elders seniors to understand them first
instead of making sure they understand
us we're number eight
follow your calling when I made this
transition into the into the business
world what I discovered was as you were
talking a moment ago the you know you
feel the tug on your heart they're kind
of like wow I started here and now I'm
over here here's what I believe I
believe that as you follow your dream it
begins it gets bigger and when it gets
bigger there are there are more things
that you're learning about it that you
didn't know when you started this in the
beginning the dream is just you know
it's just very little and you can kind
of see it so you go that way but then it
begins then it begins to expand yes and
for me it's a calling and let me just
say this I'm not trying to be over
spiritual but somebody asked me today
what a calling was and I like kind of my
new definition for call okay in fact in
my and my book leadership's I one of my
chapters is shifting from career to
calling and how you know how you know
perfectly and how do i how do I make
that [ __ ] but I think I think a calling
is a is a purpose with a divine touch
rule number nine serve if you want 2019
to be the year that you really want to
be here is here so here's the secret of
making it a great year every day serve
someone every day every day I had value
to people every day serve one every day
live the intentional life of doing for
others sometimes what they cannot do for
themselves and if you will put people
first and add value to them and serve
them it becomes absolutely amazing what
you and I are going to have and achieve
how we're going to help people and in
return how it comes back to us Benjamin
Franklin said this no one is useless in
this world who lightens the burden of
someone else if you're if you're helping
someone else lift a load in your life
you
a very useful person Mahatma Gandhi said
that the best way to find yourself is to
lose yourself in the service of others
but perhaps on this kind of a theme my
favorite quote is from Albert Schweitzer
who said I don't know what your destiny
will be but one thing I do know the only
ones among you who will be really happy
are those who have sought and found how
to serve but he's right on the happiest
people are not always the most
successful people but they're the ones
who serve the best I've met a lot of
unhappy successful people haven't you
but I've never met never met an unhappy
person that gave their life of serving
and giving and adding value to other
people Martin Luther King jr. said
everybody can be great because everybody
can serve and rule number 10 the last
one before a very special bonus clip is
love what you do you're probably
wondering is there more for John Maxwell
at this age are you finished writing are
you starting a whole new thing are you
you're not gonna stop dreaming no I'm
not even I I'm in fact I'm having the
greatest time of my life I'm learning
more right now than I've ever learned
through the John Maxwell Leadership
Foundation we're doing transformation in
countries and we're seeing greater
changes and than I've ever seen before
and people will come say well when are
you gonna retire you know I'm not going
to retire that doesn't seem to satisfy
them so I just tell them when I die I'll
retire you know
I won't do any more speak II don't write
any more books when I'm dead I'm dead
but I think I think what I want to do is
live until I die and not get the two
confused you know what I mean
now I've got a really special bonus cut
from John on how to keep growing that I
think you're really gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the three
point landing questions time to go from
just watching another video to taking
action in your life for business and if
you're feeling bold leave your answers
in the comments below here we go
question number one how can you serve
someone today number two what do you
need to just start moving on today and
number three what mindset shift do you
need to make the greatest detriment of
Tamar's successes today's success mm-hmm
because I 10 Asiya is for me what I'm
successful at to hold on to it's okay
okay let's not change anything
we've got the formula we got it down or
making some good money we're helping
some people so let's let's steal this
kind of box it and kind of set it apart
and let's keep it just as it is and of
course that's a disaster in fact that's
one of the reasons why I wrote the book
leadership's is because I I wanted to
help I wanted to help people understand
that that there's no such thing as
leading people the same way forever
that you have to keep learning and
growing and and and shifting and making
those shifts in your life
if you want more John Maxwell check it
the first top ten rules video I made on
him the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
and that never quite rang true with me
there's something for nothing
entitlement mindset that invades so many
people's lives